Two bedroom, two bathrooms, 1300 square feet,
waterfront luxury apartment with a dope view,
great amenities like a swimming pool.
I'll never use and also private marinas,
but no one can afford a boat because the rent is too high.
So welcome to my crib, that a sheriff to a roommate.
What's poppin.
Welcome to my new and improved the apartment because I'm hella rich.
Now that YouTube money,
dude, I can't give you a ride. I don't have a car. Why don't you have a car,
dude? I spend all my money on this apartment. I can't afford a car. Boom.
Anyways, the first part of the tour is the kitchen.
First is a super cool Japanese knives. Look at this amazing.
It's actually only this one's fine,
but we also have a super cool marble Island, which is really,
really nice.
And then we have this super cool rice cooker that actually uses machine
learning technology to cook the rice perfectly. And it's actually true.
I'm not joking. It's like fuzzy logic. You should search it up. Unfortunately,
my roommates are not home, so we have like no groceries.
So there's probably going to be empty. Oh my God, what blue apron?
It's not empty at all. This video is sponsored by blue apron. Ah,
thank you so much. Blue apron for sponsoring this video.
So now I can pay my boy Matt show. So don't forget.
The first 50 people to sign up will get $50 off their first two weeks with blue
apron. Just click on the description down below. Oh wait,
Matt, can you cook for me while Matt is cooking the food?
Let me tell you a little bit about our sponsor. So blue apron,
it allows you to create delicious chef designed recipes at home.
So it's super convenient, perfect to impress a hot date.
And the thing I liked the most about it,
price start as low as seven 49 per serving,
which is way cheaper than eating out, which is perfect for people who are cheap.
Like me also, if you have commendment issues like me,
it's okay, because you can skip or cancel the service at any time.
So if you're interested,
please click the link in the description box and get $50 off your first two
weeks. It really helps support blue apron and also my channel.
So yeah, [inaudible]
all right back to the apartment tour. Now next let's check out the dining area.
Wow. Oh my God. Matt show.
Thank you for leaving all your junk on my dining table. But yeah,
when macho isn't here,
it's like a beautiful dining table and there's chess set and we usually eat
here, but Oh, well. And then let's go to the living room.
My favorite thing about my living room is the projector because you can Netflix
and chill or even better. My YouTube channel, Hey, was topping.
So then the next thing is, Oh yeah, let's check this off. You know,
if you're watching TV, you could plug your phone and charge your I-phones.
And if you're an Android user, what is too bad,
but it doesn't matter because your battery probably isn't trash. All right.
And then if you go over to this couch,
you could see my beautiful metal corgis, but you know,
what's cuter my little group assistant right here.
So Groot is actually my lighting assistant,
which is pretty cool because I could tell him to turn on the lights and he will
check this out group, turn on the light. Oh.
I'll get checked out. Turn off the light group.
Turn off the light. Okay. Um,
sometimes groups can be a little bit stubborn, but I love him. All right.
So next let's check out the coffee table.
Now what does a coffee table need a coffee book?
So this is twice really cute. Love my love, my K-pop stuff. All right.
And that's it for the living room. Let's go to my room. All right.
And to make sure that people know that's my bedroom, we got this big, big Moji.
And also we got my roommate greeting people coming in and also my dope
painting. All right. Let's go to my room. Come on in, come on in.
So welcome to my bedroom where all the magic happens and by magic,
I mean the magic of editing. But yeah, anyways, if you look over here,
you're going to see a painting of a girl,
which is probably the closest thing I'll ever get to having a girl. My bedroom.
Anyways, I do like paintings. So,
which is why I have three paintings over here. This is abstract art.
It's pretty hard to comprehend the meaning of this.
So I'm not even gonna bother trying to explain to you guys. All right.
So here's my station, my battle station, where I edit all my videos,
got my microphone and my a tissue box. Stan got my LG monitor,
got my laptop. And Oh my God, we got a Kiwi bird. So cute.
And then we also have the ducks here. Pretty cute. Here.
We have my personal laptop that I use to watch my favorite videos on red too.
I mean on YouTube red.
And then here is a lot of gorilla pods for filming and stuff like that on my
hard drive. Oh wow. Here. I got four iPhone,
you know, one for each girl, not just testing devices, but whatever.
And then finally my beautiful bed.
I do miss my bunk bed. You know? I mean,
you guys complain about my bunk beds saying like, Oh my God,
why you still have a bunk ban or shut a door? Or here we go,
I got a queen size bed. No. And guess what?
It's actually such a waste of space because I literally sleep like this.
So there's so much space time wasting. Oh my God.
And it's not like I have a girlfriend.
So if you're a girl I'm watching this video,
don't forget to slide into my dance. Cool. My kidding man.
I don't have any girls viewership anyways.
Let's go to the bathroom and onto the bathroom.
Now let's see what I have here. I have some cotton pads, cued tips.
I got toothbrush. I got makeup roof mover for my non-existent girlfriend.
And then also I got these little cloth they're super expensive,
but I thought there were something else anyways.
And then the great thing about this bathroom is that you can watch a videos.
Wow. You get ready.
And also the cool thing about this surface book is that you can actually detach
it. Look at this.
Oh my.
God. I hate surface books, man. They always break.
Okay. So I can't attach it right now because the surface book sucks.
Oh.
My God. It's Oh my God. Okay. It's working now.
And you get to attach it and watch your favorite videos while you take a
shower, you know, so you can be entertained.
And then it's also attached to this. Uh, what is it? Youi boom speaker.
So you can make it real loud.
Are you kidding? Right.
[inaudible].
All right. In case you're wondering why I bought a surface book.
I did not buy a surface book. Okay.
I got the surface book for free when I did an internship on Microsoft.
And the reason why they gave it out for free is because they know that this
piece of hardware will become irrelevant. Just like my YouTube channel.
But anyways, so, okay, this. Let's put it back.
And this is the worst tour ever.
Okay.
Uh, anyways, let's talk about this mirror.
A lot of people love this mirror because it's perfect for selfies,
but I think it's a little bit too Bryce because it covers all my flaws,
my complexion, and also my deep insecurities that repressed 20 years ago.
But it also makes my abs look good. So I guess that's fine, but yeah,
let's wrap up the tour. So come on out. All right.
Thank you so much for checking out the tour with me. Now,
if you liked this video, don't forget to like and subscribe. So yeah.
Hope you enjoyed the tour and have a great day. Peace.
Can you feel me a little bit again? Okay. Peace out.
[Inaudible].
That's about it. Can you do it? We'll sakes, man.
That's it for new form of the tour. Thank you so, so much.